bonsoir a tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver au sommaire de ça vous regarde
ce soir le coronavirus aura-t-il raison
des municipales le gouvernement écarte
pour l'heure tout report des élections
les 15 et 22 mars prochain mais sur le
terrain dans les zones à risque certains
candidats se plaignent de difficultés à
faire campagne alors que faire si par
endroits une partie de la population est
confiné dans un quartier ou dans une
ville
est-ce que la sincérité du scrutin
serait alors entachée coronavirus
questions autour d'une élection c'est
notre grand débat ce soir
pour lui l'économie est un sport de
combat qui revendique sa part
d'idéologie il avait cartonné avec son
traité d'économie hérétiques il revient
avec un livre programme les délaissés ou
comment unir les victimes de la
mondialisation pour prendre le pouvoir
thomas porsche deviendra nous en parler
dans la deuxième partie de cette
émission et puis notre groupe témoin ce
soit s'est lancé un défi gigantesque
ressusciter le parti socialiste les
municipales sont pour lui un enjeu
crucial
olivier faur le premier secrétaire du ps
est avec nous ce soir voilà donc pour le
programme ces partis hashtag sévère
n'oubliez pas où il va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir olivier
faur bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
notre grand témoin vous êtes député
socialiste de cinéma patron du parti
socialiste on va parler de l'avenir de
votre parti il ya des municipales qui
sont un enjeu prioritaire un enjeu
capital pour pour vous pour votre parti
mais ces municipales en pleine crise du
grenat virus et bien vont être forcément
quelque peu perturbé le gouvernement
nous dit ce soir qu'elles ne seront pas
annulées cette élection on en parle avec
vous carole bureau bonnart bonsoir ne
sont vous êtes député la république en
marche de l'oise l'un des départements
les plus touchés par l'épidémie une
trentaine de communes un beau me didier
avant avant le direct et et toucher un
nouveau décès dans votre département
99,4 contamination dans cette région
dont le maire de crépy en valois
vous allez nous dire en fait ce qui se
passe chez vous ce qui se passe dans
cette campagne est ce que les candidats
font campagne où est-ce qu'elle s'est
arrêtée
bruno cautrès bonsoir et merci d'être là
vous êtes professeur à sciences po paris
chercheur cnrs au cevipof vous publié
aujourd'hui elle s'agite grande vaste
enquête du cevipof sur la confiance dans
la politique des français vous nous en
direz un mot qui peut annuler un scrutin
peut-on le faire dans certaines villes
et pas dans d'autres
quelles sont les conséquences politiques
on verra cela avec vous enfin bonsoir
jean marie vilain franchement merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes le maire de
viry châtillon dans l'essonne candidat
votre réélection vous nous direz au fond
si vous estimez que c'est les
municipalités sont assez informés assez
armé pour faire face à ce scrutin un
petit peu particulier je vous donne la
parole dans un instant celui qui nous
plante le décor comme tous les soirs à
sa manière avec son ton et son regard
c'est stéphane blakowski si j'ai bien
compris tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous enfin
stéphane si j'ai bien compris ce soir si
j'ai bien compris myriam ça y est le
corps n'a virus est sur le point de
faire une nouvelle victime aaron savez
l'économie française est affaibli et
elle est malade mais là la nouvelle
victime qui pourrait être contaminée ce
sont les élections municipales
on aurait pu s'en douter que fait un
candidat pendant l'élection municipale
il passe son temps à serrer des mains
dans un moment on n'a plus droit de
serrer les mains de personnes comment
faire campagne
donc voyez c'est incontestable
l'élection va être perturbée on est même
obligé de se poser la question est ce
que ça ne serait pas prudent plus sage
de reporter l'élection une date
ultérieure par j on est obligé de se
poser la question je m'emballe un peu
parce que figurez-vous que le
gouvernement alors là ça ne leur avait
jamais mais jamais traversé l'esprit
on écoute jacqueline gourault ministre
des territoires il est venu à l'esprit
de personne de reculer les élections
municipales et au moment où je vous
parle ce n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
donc on peut avoir la certitude qu'elles
auront lieu ces élections municipales
dans toute la france dans dix jours je
ne vous raconte comme j'écris micro au
moment où je vous parle c'est une
certitude mais forçant le fait de
préciser que ça vaut au moment où on
parle ça le supposer que demain la
situation va peut-être changer que on
fera peut-être fini m'en tenir compte de
d'épidémie donc voilà ne prêtons pas de
mauvaises pensées gouvernement déjà
quelque part philippe a été accusé
d'avoir passé passer en douce de 49,3 en
profitant de la crise du crâne un virus
le gouvernement où nous convaincre que
pas du tout alors là parce que ça pour
est son intérêt après tout il est
municipale se présentent pas très bien
si on les reporte est ce que ça serait
pas un atout pour gouvernants non
rassurez-vous non si bête ndiaye a mis
tout son enthousiasme hier sur france
inter pour inciter les français à aller
voter mais vraiment j'ai un message à
l'attention de tous nos concitoyens
il n'y a pas de panique à avoir on prend
des mesures au fur à mesure étayées
scientifiquement et il faut pas avoir
peur d'aller aux élections c'est un très
beau moment démocratique il faut aller
mal et on va pas les emplois allaient
voter ne pas avoir peur du court au
navire il faut pas clairement ce matin
il faut pas ne pas aller voter parce
qu'on a peur du comment des virus voilà
malgré cet appel enthousiasme
enthousiaste aux urnes
il peut y avoir quand même un risque
celui de voir l'abstention augmente et
baisse est quasiment certain ça puisque
la cour de l'estanque l'abstention est
en augmentation constante il s est
montré les chiffres il sait pas pas
besoin d'épidémie régulièrement
l'abstention augmente donc c'était un
record qui a été battu aux dernières
municipales en 2014 à 36 points on peut
imaginer que l'abstention va encore
augmenter
pour ces municipales avec en plus
l'épidémie il faut dire que dans
certaines régions on est vraiment
touchés par le virus
ça peut être même un peu inquiétant
d'aller faire la queue devant le bureau
de vote avec des gens qui toussent de
rentrer dans l'isoloir ou plein de gens
sont passés ont mis leurs mains partout
puis prendre ce silo la quête d'un coup
tout le monde la sait vous êtes un peu
stressé avec samir m ouais pourquoi ça
tombe sur moi vraiment n'ont pas du tout
apprécié jusqu'à magique vous deviez
voter dans l'oise par exemple ou
vraiment il ya des risques
ben oui ça fait réfléchir c'est pour ça
que le président des maires de l'oise
lui il a proposé donc il a donné
l'interview courrier picard de reporter
voire d'un mois ou deux l'élection dont
on écoute les arguments qui est qu'il
dès qu'ils déploient moi je considère
que dans des villes où il y avait des
bureaux de vote qui peuvent rassembler
au moment du vote 25 ou 30 ou 40
personnes
le risque de contamination peut exister
c'est vrai que si on a un taux
d'abstention relativement sensibles cela
aura un impact des victimes en sur le
résultat du vote
c'est la grande question au fresquel
coronavirus va fausser le résultat de
ces sûr c'est que pour tous ceux qui
vous êtes battus pendant ces municipales
ils ont une excuse toute trouvée
mais oui mais avec le contexte de
l'épidémie forcément le scrutin a été
faussé l'aurait gagné je jouerai comme
ça si j'étais battu un bon en même temps
si on était fiable qu est ce qui va se
passer a priori les catégories
d'électeurs qui sont le plus
susceptibles de ne pas aller voter ces
thèmes les plus âgés c'est là que le
taux de mortalité augmente donc la
question c'est de savoir mais pour
qu'ils votent en majorité les seniors
bien regarder aux européennes pour qui
les majors mince très pudique en marche
qui a évidemment 33% de plus de 65 ans
évidemment le convainc de maquereau est
a priori celui qui va être le plus
exposé au risque d'abstention qui
pourrait augmenter
donc ben pour l'instant il est bien sûr
pas question de reporter les municipales
enfin c'est au moment où je vous parle
ce n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
on va parler dans le détail des
problèmes très concrets et très pratique
qui se posent
dans l'organisation de ce scrutin mais
mais cette question du report je te pose
franchement
écoutez si vous pensez que la démocratie
peut être mises en danger par le corona
virus au moment où on se parle on se
parlera
on sait car il faut arrêter la vie
économique qui ferait il arrêtait les
transports il faut arrêter les écoles si
vous pensez que le simple contact ça
peut faire dans une file avec des gens
qui comme vous vont aller voter est plus
contagieux que d'aller au travail
j'ai du mal à cerner c'est pas plus
dangereux que d'aller au supermarché
s'il ya vraiment un danger effectivement
tout va s'arrêter
mais je ne pense pas d'ailleurs que ce
soit la bonne idée que de donner ce
signal là il y à une épidémie qui va
venir
on le sait la réalité c'est que tout le
monde sait que l'épidémie arrive mais la
meilleure façon de lutter contre
l'épidémie est d'abord de ne pas céder à
la psychose
parce que la psycho ça veut dire
l'encombrement des services de médecine
de ville comme l'hôpital public et
chacun sait qu'ils sont déjà très
largement sollicité donc c'est pas la
peine de venir avec ses angoisses quand
il ya des gens qui ont besoin d'être
traités et puis voilà il faut que chacun
fasse preuve de civisme et le civisme
menacé d'arrêter de se serrer la main sa
tête se fait la bise faire campagne sans
serrer les mains et sans faire la bise
c'est difficile c'est vrai c'est plus
compliqué mais on entend le chef de
parti que vous êtes appelés voilà un
petit peu à l'apaisement pas pas de
panique il faut honorer ce rendez vous
démocratique la réalité c'est que si
nous cédons à la panique ce sera plus
difficile quand tu te soigner ce virus
enfin de le maintenir de le tenir à
distance et donc effectivement il faut
que chacun c'est une épreuve collective
dont elle suppose que chacun d'entre
nous prenne sa part de l'effort et donc
première chose c'est de ne pas aller
perturber les services médicaux qui
n'ont pas besoin de nous enfin de ceux
qui supportent bien pour donc traiter
les angoisses de chacun
on va aller sur le terrain avec vous
nous raconter car le bureau bonheur
commence à cette campagne
elle est perturbée à arrêter non elle
n'est pas arrêtée elle est simplement
perturbé vous l'avez entendu il y à des
dispositions particulières qui ont été
prises par arrêté préfectoral pour
éviter les réunions politiques qui
pourrait être un signe un endroit où des
contacts pourraient se faire tuer
lièrement mais mon vivent les habitants
ça sont faits d'un comprendre il ya ce
scrutin lui arrive mais il faut rappeler
qu'il ya plusieurs élus confiné
également alors qu'on ressent sur le
terrain
il ya déjà une appréhension bien entendu
il ya beaucoup de questions
moi je réponds aussi beaucoup aux par
les réseaux sociaux me fait les utiliser
aussi peu de cette manière là pour bien
expliquer aussi s'en aller sur une
psychose au sens aller sur des parfois
des choses que l'on entend même des
faits que news pour par rapport à lacets
de contamination il faut être prudent on
redonne les les gestes qu'il faut éviter
et ce qu'il faut faire comme vous disiez
se laver les mains bien entendu faire
attention c'est évident et puis par
rapport à la campagne ou par rapport à
ce qui se passe dans l'oise c'est plus
que le terrain c'est plus compliqué mais
bon des gens défavorisés
non mais on faisait dans un cluster ils
sont où tout le monde n'a pas n'a pas la
possibilité justement de faire deux
réunions politiques donc tout le monde
est au même niveau de ce côté là bien
sûr que le maire qui est confiné et qui
est candidat à sa serre et à sa
réélection pardon ne peut pas aller sur
le terrain cinq policiers le fond à sa
place exactement il y à son équipe
et puis ensuite les parts par facebook
ça se fait dès facebook live et puis une
communication différente
un exemple concret les candidats moins
connus qui essaye au fonds de se lancer
dans cette bataille là pour la première
défavorisés parce qu'il ya moins de
réunions publiques ou moins de monde
dans les réunions publiques par rapport
au maire sortant que l'on de koné
écoutez je crois que même les derniers
jours de campagne est tellement de
différences entre les campagnes et
chaque chaque candidat politique à une
manière différente de le faire il y en a
beaucoup qui font plutôt sur du porte à
porte mais qui sont aussi plutôt dans un
contact personnel
donc ils continuent à le faire il ya des
marchés même dans l'oise donc des
marchés qui sont restés ouverts hors des
clusters donc les gens continuent
groupement distribution de tracts voilà
mais pas notamment dans les clusters ou
là évidemment les marchés ont été
interdits quelques lecteurs choisis le
cellier de contamination interne un
instant c'est bien d'avoir leur exemple
le point presse quotidien de bruno
salomon qui dit qui est directeur de la
santé 423 personnes contaminées ce soir
dans le pays soit 138 de plus qui hier
voilà cette épidémie est elle arrive
pour autant dans votre département et la
circonscription mais l'ensemble du
département
vous ne souhaitez pas comme le président
des maires que non pas par porter aux
non là je rejoins olivier faure je crois
que et puis beaucoup de deux de mes
collègues mais aussi beaucoup d'élus il
faut cette élection doit avoir lieu à
l'heure actuelle nous pouvons nous
pouvoir les baby mais parce que je veux
dire on peut en sourire mais
effectivement c'est comme ça que
fonctionne lorsque nous avons soir
risque d'épidémie ou un élément comme
celui là avec un virus il se peut que
dans une semaine on change notre fusil
d'épaulé ou dans quinze jours ou dans
trois semaines on sait que l'épidémie en
tout cas arrive un petit peu on voyait
bien les cas se multiplient pourquoi
parce qu'il ya aussi des dépistages
supplémentaire c'est ça qu'il faut dire
et puis on a donc cessé éléments qui
vont faire qu'il y aura une augmentation
et c'est mieux c'est une transparence on
peut pas non plus je trouve que c'est
l'étape 2 on cherchait à éviter que le
virus se répandant contre cela qu'on met
des barrières il en a trois qui ai marre
et plus grave en fait
à moins d'un master mais toujours qu'il
faut respecter aussi cette appréhension
de nos concitoyens il faudra donc ma
disposition certainement particulière
notamment dans les départements et
dernière quelques angoisses vous
concerne vous craignez pas qu'a
posteriori ces élections ont lieu elles
seront lieu un selon toute vraisemblance
que des candidats avaient fait recours
en disant rupture de l'égalité
c'était pas juste moi je ne sais pas ça
je crois que nous allons pouvoir en
parler juste après non à partir du
moment où le ministère de l'intérieur et
le ministre l'indiqué les élections se
se déroule c'est que ce sera fait dans
les règles
après je voulais simplement les élèves
du département de loi simplement dire
que nous avons vraiment un grand travail
de nos soignants actuellement et qu'il
faut continuer aussi à les soutenir par
rapport à ce virus qui se propage et
puis avoir une pensée parce que c'est
vrai que là on part les élections de
salaberry pensée aussi pour les familles
ont touché particulièrement dans mon
département
je crois par rapport à ce virus qu'on
connaît c'est mal qui est arrivé assez
brutalement et qui perturbe beaucoup les
vies de nos concitoyens oddo cautrès on
va parler de ce qui peut changer à dans
les conséquences politiques abstention
ou pas mais déjà d'une façon très
pratique est ce qu'on peut annuler un
scrutin est ce que c'est possible
pas du lait un scrutin on peut leur
apporter on peut reporter sa déjà été
pratiqué on a déjà procédé à des reports
des élections
lorsqu'en 2002 il y avait eu la version
du calendrier électoral ça avait été
fait mais pas annulé évidemment oui bien
sûr mais il faudrait une loi votée de
toute urgence de ce avant le 15 a
annoncé le mandat des maires actuels
damman alors je partage à la fois le
point de vue des élus qui étaient
développés effectivement si on arrête
les élections alors est-ce qu'on va pour
qu'on n'arrête pas de travailler aussi
donc je partage ça mais en même temps je
soulignerai de deux éléments qui me
semble important si on se place du point
de vue du citoyen qui essayent de lire
tout ceci le premier élément c'est un
besoin de cohérence effectivement c'est
à dire si je peux pas me rendre pour mes
vacances à l'étranger
si je peux pas aller dans tel endroit et
c'est donc il ya un besoin de cohérence
et de lisibilité de ses rangs une
difficulté une difficulté l'interdiction
de transmettre une image
un message qui soit lisible dans sa
cohérence et qu'on ait le sentiment que
les décisions sont en soi transports en
commun par exemple cohérent et puis un
deuxième aspect qui effectivement ce qui
était ce qui était souligné à l'instant
de faire tout ce qui est possible pour
que aucun candidat n'est le sentiment
aucun citoyenne et le sentiment qu'il ya
eu une rupture c'est vrai que la base
une campagne électorale c'est non
seulement serrer les mains mais c'est
aussi de pouvoir tenir réunion publique
sariska vous disais en tout cas en tout
cas le climat général il peut
incontestablement peut-être favorisé un
peu plus d'abstention c'est pas
exactement l'abstention c'est toujours
très difficile à mesurer dans les
enquêtes d'opinion avant les élections
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya potentiellement
là un enjeu besoin d'une politique
publique et non seulement de santé
publique et sanitaire par rapport à
l'épidémie
mais là il ya besoin d'une très actif
politiques publiques sur l'organisation
comme concept cohérent ça surtout les
élections qui est ce qui pénalise est
généralement enfin moi je vais faire un
rapprochement avec des raisonnements
avec l'usagé mais qui selon vous a plus
de chances d'être pénalisé par
l'abstention qui augmente leur demande
alors il ya des électorats qui n'ont pas
le même potentiel de mobilisation
certain électorat sont plus mobilisés
que d'autres lois l'électorat du
rassemblement national est un électorat
qui à la fois très fidèle à ses
candidats très avec une une mobilisation
qui est relativement forte en même temps
c'est un électorat qui a une composition
sociologique qu'il éloigne un peu de la
participation donc c'est un peu
compliqué de le dire exactement qui va
qui va bénéficier mais en tout cas ça ça
aura un effet sans aucun doute sur le
niveau 2 sur le niveau de participation
dans les zones qui sont les zones les
plus explosées ajouter quelque chose
est ce que vous vous parliez
effectivement de l'abstention bien là je
crois que les spéciales va reparler
après cinq ans politique vous avez
certainement entendu la déclaration
aussi odieux ministre de l'intérieur ou
à une réflexion se fait aussi sur la
possibilité de faire beaucoup plus de
procurations notamment dans les fameux
gloucester rouler
et les regroupements bien entendu mais
aussi dans les départements qui seront
touchés avec des agents qui ne seront
pas obligatoirement de police judiciaire
pour pouvoir mettre aussi en place pour
que vraiment ce qu'ils ont envie de
voter et les personnes y apposer leurs
additions comment il faut quand même
aller mais jose maria savez que quand on
est abreuvé les gendarmes se déplacent
habituellement pour pouvoir justement
les personnes âgées n'auront pas cette
voie là exactement comme protection des
agents et à des adéquat bien entendu et
c'est ce qui est en train d'être avec le
ministre la ministre de la justice
alors il ya eu et je me tourne vers vous
dans un instant une réunion d'élus tout
à l'heure au ministère de la cohésion
des territoires avec vous le voyez
jacqueline gourault christophe castaner
et sébastien lecornu réunion avec
également des représentants
d'associations d'élus à commencer par
françois baroin le patron de
l'association des maires de france on va
écouter christophe castel
il y aura une communication à l'entrée
des bureaux de vote sur les bons
comportements pour limiter les risques
il y a aussi des engagements notamment
des prêts faits pour faire en sorte que
les communes qui connaîtraient des
difficultés pour pouvoir disposer de gel
hydroalcoolique à l'entrée du bureau de
vote puisse avoir l'appui des prêts
faits je donnerai des instructions ce
sens certaines personnes peuvent venir
et ce n'est pas obligatoire ce n'est pas
recommandé
ça n'est pas interdit peuvent venir avec
un masque dans ce cas là il appartiendra
au président du bureau de vote
d'apprécier s'il est en mesure de
reconnaître la personnalité en rapport
avec la pièce d'identité proposé
n'appartiendra pas au maire d'annuler le
scrutin parce que certains pourraient
avoir la tentation surtout s'il ne se
représente pas de vouloir faire durer
leur mandat non la situation actuelle
permet de considérer que les élections
devraient avoir lieu le même jour le 15
et 22 mars sur l'ensemble du territoire
national en france métropolitaine et en
outre mer
jean-marie vilain elle vous rassure ces
différentes mesures préconisations là on
parle du scrutin du jour j
l'organisation de ce jour j d'abord ils
n'avaient pas besoin de me rassurer
parce qu'on n'a pas attendu que que
monsieur castaner nous nous préconise de
mettre ni des du gel à l'entrée des
bureaux de vote ni le nécessaire pour
pouvoir nettoyer les stylos assez
régulièrement pendant toute la durée du
questions à ces mesures sont d'ores et
déjà été prises de la même façon on a
prévenu les entreprises qui est en
charge de tout ce qui est savons
serviette et cetera de l'endroit où se
tiennent les bureaux de vote justement
de d'être suffisamment approvisionné
pour qu'il ait pas le moindre souci
les assesseurs on a également en réserve
justement les normalement les candidats
sont censés avoir déjà présenté un
nombre d'assesseurs important pour
pouvoir pour que les élections puissent
se tenir correctement et régulièrement
ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
d'ailleurs parce que beaucoup dont on
parle beaucoup souvent des parcs des
partis qui ne seraient pas à la hauteur
de ce que les gens attendent sauf que
les parties ont aussi cette cette
capacité à mobiliser beaucoup de monde
beaucoup de militants pour justement
tenir ses bureaux de vote et j'ai
souvenir qu aux dernières élections
légistatives en particulier on avait des
candidats qui se réclamait de
différentes sensibilités politiques mais
qui arrivait avec leurs affiches leurs
bulletins de vote la profession de foi
et qui demandait surtout aux maires et
aux assesseurs qui voulait bien faire le
déplacement
las de faire le boulot pendant toute la
journée là en l'occurrence ce n'est pas
le cas les par les grands partis en
général justement mobilise assez bien
pour pouvoir tenir et que la démocratie
puisse apparaissait le canada est
important vous fournirez les militants
des cfc de dire nous nous avons demandé
aussi d'avoir dix candidats
supplémentaires pour tenir si bon pour
le dépouillement ne fait pas de problème
je rappelle que voilà on dépouille les
enveloppes ont toutes les enveloppes
mais de l'amas de l'arrière je pense que
les candidats pour tout à l'heure et est
tout à fait juste je pense qu'on ne peut
pas le rater un
un moment de démocratie aussi important
pour les habitants
pour les communes on leur doit on leur
doit et puis quand tu as quant à la
campagne en elle-même
je pense que lorsqu'on a une réelle
envie de prendre justement de travailler
pour la collectivité
on n'attend pas les six mois officiel de
campagne électorale pour venir à la
rencontre des habitants et je pense que
théoriquement on est en mesure d'avoir
rencontré ses habitants pendant les
années précédant
là on est à un carrefour de confiance et
à la confiance dans le système de santé
dans la parole des politiques et puis à
la confiance au fond dans le bulletin de
vote c'est à dire il faut avoir double
confiance pour avoir envie de voter bien
être des gens qui sont confinés cela
qu'est ce qu'on fait
se déplacer il reste à la maison ou
ration procuration jusqu au dimanche
jusqu'au 10 le sco dit mentionnant ce
qui existe aussi à cas des conditions
aujourd'hui sont drastiques peut-être
faut-il laisser athènes pour pouvoir
permettre ce vote par correspondance et
se créant plusieurs là un enjeu qui est
très important et je disais tout à
l'heure d'organiser de manière très très
très solide
les conditions de déroulement de ces
élections municipales effectivement vote
par procuration vote par correspondance
conjuration éventuellement mais ce
dimanche et surtout je pense beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'information des
citoyens pour que personne n'est le
sentiment que
c'est pas quoi faire le jour du vote la
fiv est masquée il faut y aller est ce
que c'est autorisé d'y aller les gens se
posent beaucoup de questions tout à
l'heure monaco presse vous disiez
attention au manque de lisibilité de
certaines mesures
c'est vrai que peut-être si on passe en
phase iii alors les gestes barrières
seront plus utiles ce qui n'est pas
forcément compréhensible par tous ou
parfois il ya même des décisions qui
semblent contradictoires sur sur
l'interdiction certains rassemblements
en même temps est les français ont-ils
confiance puisque vous publiez votre
baromètre aujourd'hui dans le système de
santé dans les hôpitaux
dans ces moments de crise là dans la
parole publique la confiance dans les
hôpitaux est très très élevé
on mesure de la confiance dans les
institutions publiques et c'est
l'hôpital qui arrive en tête avec 80% de
confiance la confiance dans le système 2
200 t on à 69% de confiance dans la
sécurité sociale la confiance dans le
système de santé des français ont sans
doute plus confiance dans les médecins
dans les praticiens le système de santé
déjà introduit chez les français l'idée
que tout le monde n'a pas un accès égal
au plan territorial le plan sociologique
au système de santé qu'à des cas des
barrières donc la confiance est là quand
même dans les institutions publiques qui
sont en charge de la protection les
autorités publiques qui sont en charge
du soin font l'objet d'une très large on
va dire approbation de de confiance sans
commune mesure avec les politiques sans
commune mesure avec les institutions le
politique d'ailleurs vous avez 4 500
pour le l'hôpital les partis politiques
c'est quoi le niveau de confiance alors
il ya 13 à 13 % plus bas d'ailleurs le
plus détesté et nous les journalistes ce
trio 28 ah ouais on est vraiment c'est
un gros écart est un gros écart
qu'est ce que le politologue que vous
êtes peut nous dire deux hauts fourneaux
qu'un formant un scrutin comme celui là
dans une crise vous pensez que
l'abstention sera août d'autant plus
haute que les crânes sont là ou pas
c'est sûr que le climat de crainte et
d'anxiété n'est pas très favorable au
fait d' aller d'aller participer à des
événements publics je parle pas
seulement des élections dont qui peut
potentiellement avoir un effet sur
l'absentionnisme l'abstention aux
élections municipales ça a été rappelé
tout à l'heure
a grandi à partir fondamentalement de la
fin des années 1980 l été on avait deux
tiers de participation pratiquement aux
élections municipales de 2002 2014
ça reste quand même un niveau
relativement important parmi toutes les
élections locales c'est quand même les
élections municipales qui sont les plus
participative
mais c'est vrai qu'il faut tout faire
pour essayer d'encourager les électeurs
à se rendre et le maire a toujours les
lui préférer le maire et la vulve et
référence à 63% de confiance sur le
maire 39 10 ans que le député gerald
urbana est question pour rester assez
pratique est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer
un report locale ça ça existe
il ya dans le code de la santé le
ministre de la santé peut prendre et la
donation s'il ya une crise sanitaire
je ne l'espère pas grand dans votre
développement qu'elle souhaite qu'elle
devienne encore plus aiguë mais non plus
comment est-ce qu'on peut on se reporte
c'est une élection municipale à un
endroit dans une ou deux communes et pas
dans l'ensemble du pays
en tout cas moi je vous dit ça où ça
pose un problème juridique je pense que
ce ne serait pas correct ne serait ce
que par souci un peu d'égalité ou
d'équité c'est à dire que comme vous le
savez on fait attention lorsque vous
nous avez les élections de ne pas donner
les résultats avant la fermeture de
l'ensemble des bureaux de vote
si vous avez en plus des votes qui sont
pas des élections pardon qui sont
reportés
de combien d'ailleurs parce que comme
l'épidémie sévit des millets si un stade
3 qui arrive et même là actuellement
dans combien de temps en effet ces
élections et donc il ya vraiment un
report qui ne serait pas bénéfique je
pense pour personne et d'ailleurs il
peut demande le demande je crois que
c'est ça c'est simplement que le maire
oui effectivement c'est la personne je
crois et l'élu le plus aimé je suis
moi-même conseillère municipale juste et
premier adjoint de la ville de noyon
donc je sais aussi cet attachement que
nous avons avec nos concitoyens je
voulais dire simplement que c'est aussi
eux et vous l'avez dit qu'ils vont faire
en sorte que ces élections se passent au
mieux et est donc cette la parole qui
peuvent avoir les uns et les autres est
important et simplement sûr je reviens
un peu sur ce que vous avez dit où on ne
sait pas trop pourquoi cela s'est arrêté
achetions que la jeunesse l'agent je
vais la communication elle est quand
même pour moi clair après que l'on
puisse se poser la question mais
pourquoi ils font ça
rigueur je dis je crois qu'à un moment
c'est là le directeur il faut être
difficilement compréhensible mais
l'arrêté par exemple la dernière navale
à nice vous laisser jouer un match de
foot à lyon turin c'est vrai voilà
simplement ça va ça peut logiquement
semblé effusion de sang faisons
confiance aux spécialistes politiques
déjà par deux pour rassurer sa
population estrosi après une décision
qui était peut-être plus que ce qu'on
demandait après je vois les politiques
aussi haut qu'il ya de la politique
évidemment dans cette crise comment vous
vous regardez au jour le jour puisque sa
situation est très évolutive la gestion
n'est pas à l'exécutif de cette qualité
j'ai fait un choix
depuis le démarrage de cette crise c'est
de ne pas justement faire rentrer la
politique politicienne dans une affaire
qui a peu touché des milliers voire des
millions de françaises et de français
dans un moment comme celui-là ça suppose
que on peut avoir des désaccords et je
peux même prouvé qu'elle ait des
décisions qui sont incohérentes mais je
ne les commente jamais parce que c'est
difficile de gérer une crise comme celle
là et j'imagine que celles et ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui au gouvernement quand
ils sont même incohérent ils le font
parce que même tâtonne et que c'est
difficile de prendre les bonnes
décisions au bon moment et que on sait
pas très bien géré virus c'est un peu un
objet inconnu et donc et on va vivre
peut-être longtemps avec parce que la
résa raison pour laquelle c'est très
difficile de dire qu'on va interrompre
les élections à tel ou tel endroit c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de saisonnalité pour le
coronavirus en réalité il est il touche
aussi bien les miss faire nord que nice
fait sud donc la température le
réchauffement avec la saison chaque
décision est chaude peut ne pas faire
disparaître le virus avec le beau temps
et donc le risque c'est que la grippe
espagnole ça a duré douze ans donc nord
paraît pas de malheur non mais
l'union n'est pas très bien sur les
mines et des politiques par exemple
mélenchon a dit que c'était un peu
fourbe de la part de douar philippe de
profiter de la crise pour présente
quelque 49,3 vous n'ai pas trouvé que
c'était instrumentaliser la crise
c'était simplement non mais moi je dis
simplement que je ne commente pas les
décisions qui sont prises sur le plan
sanitaire le 49-3 bien commenté avec
vous c'était y'a pas de problème
d'artère sont des endroits mais juste
sur l'ex l'instrumentalisation du grand
mais j'ai trouvé que le jour où le
conseil des ministres a décidé
d'utiliser le 49-3 tête un coup c'est un
ministre qui était officiellement dédié
à l'action les coronavirus et s'était
pas tout à fait ce qu'il fallait faire
et on ne peut pas donner vous dites pas
que ces fours mais pas loin quoi ce
débat très rapidement la parole pour le
conclure pour nos co 13 sur marieville a
rapidement j'avais une suggestion pour
conclure depuis quelques quelques jours
de semaine à peu près ou trois semaines
la communication du gouvernement est
très active sur le risque sanitaire est
le nouveau ministre la santé
une communication qui est plutôt d'assez
bonne qualité de ce point de vue là je
suggérerais bien omnis l'intérieur de
faire une communication de ce type main
sur l'organisation des élections
municipales à bien voilà qui est dit les
actualise la transparence beaucoup de
choses sur lesquelles il pourrait être
plus de communication christophe
castaner attendait surtout de la
communication positive et bien dire que
là de toute façon les zones où il ya
effectivement le plus le plus de cas
sont effectivement touché mais demandant
quand même une grande partie de la
france où pour le moment on est dans une
situation où il ya absolument rien et
nous prenons les dispositions en tout
cas je pense que tous mes collègues
maires les prennent pour que les
élections se passent dans les meilleures
conditions possibles et ce sera le mot
de la fin merci infiniment d'être venu
sur le plateau de lcp olivier faur vous
restez avec nous parce qu'on va après à
présent parler de votre action à
l'assemblée nationale le groupe
socialiste s'est opposé certes avec
force sur la réforme des retraites mais
de façon je dirais moins spectaculaire
que les uns sont mis votre parti a fait
le pari du fond sur la forme
pour quel résultat on voit cela avec un
arabica à l'assemblée il ya ceux qui ont
l'art du coup d'éclat vous êtes plat
comme une chambre d'enregistrement des
désirs du président que vous serez là
comme des carpes est à voter n'importe
quoi les yeux fermés hurler hurlait et
puis il y aller discret ce qu'ils disent
privilégier le fond plutôt que la forme
le groupe socialiste a choisi sa
stratégie dernier exemple en date le
texte des retraites dans votre système
cette femme qui est née en 1975 qui
commence à travailler à 22 ans comme ce
que fait toute voie d'étude d'impact qui
part qui peut partir aujourd'hui à une
retraite à taux plein à 63 ans
si elle fait le même choix dans votre
système pour partir à 63 ans elle aura
une retraite avec une décote de 5% avec
700 amendements déposés les socialistes
n'ont pas fait le jeu de l'obstruction
revendiquée par la france insoumise et
les communistes pour obtenir au final
seuls quatre amendements repris par le
gouvernement ce que nous nous sommes
efforcés de faire que ce soit dans la
défense de nos amendements ou dans les
prises de parole sur les amendements des
autres c'est d'aller au fond des sujets
à évoquer la situation de beaucoup de
métiers d'évoquer les questions de taux
de remplacement de la valeur du point
enfin beaucoup de questions techniques
qui évidemment sont des sous jacents qui
ne résiste pas aux éléments de langage
et c'est ça le choix de méthodes de
travail que nous a que nous avons fait
le groupe a même utilisé son droit de
tirage pour mettre en place une
commission denquête son but évaluer la
sincérité de l'étude d'impact sur les
retraites
demande rejetée par la majorité mais si
le groupe joue la carte du sérieux sur
32 députés seuls quelques personnalités
émergent
parmi eux olivier faure le chef du parti
la présidente du groupe à l'assemblée
valérie rabault ou encore boris vallot
porte parole et expert des subtilités de
l'assemblée
son fait d'armes avoir exhumé un article
du règlement pour contraindre le
gouvernement à mettre en place la
commission bensalah puisque la président
de la commission des lois et là je
voudrais rappeler la possibilité offerte
par l'article 5 ter de l'ordonance
numéro 58 on sent du 17 novembre 1958
qui avait permis en son temps à la
commission des lois de se doter des
compétences d'une commission d' enquête
sur l'état d'urgence
la commission benalla mais aussi le
référendum d'initiative partagée contre
la privatisation des aéroports de paris
les socialistes ont largement été à la
manoeuvre
une fierté pour le groupe même si le
rythme devrait être un échec
alors on va revenir sur ce sujet avec
vous et les efforts mais j'accueille
d'abord thomas porcher bonsoir bonsoir
merci d'être là vous allez nous parler
dans un instant de votre livre les
délaissés chez fayard c'est déjà un
carton parmi les meilleures ventes des
essais et elsa monde un gamin bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous comme chaque jour
pour le point retraite vous suivez tous
ces débats pour lcp avec un énième
peut-être le dernier coup d'éclat
cet après midi olivier faur vous êtes 30
députés socialistes à l'assemblée
c'est presque deux fois plus que les
insoumis vous êtes opposés sur les
retraites
et pourtant on entend que les insomnies
par frustrant ce qui est frustrant c'est
que la presse fasse souvent le choix du
buzz contre le choix du fonds et que ça
incite les parlementaires à être dans le
spectacle plutôt que dans l'appréciation
juste de ce qui est un projet est ce que
nous avons tenté de faire dans le débat
sur les retraites c'est de pouvoir
utiliser le bas la raison pour laquelle
nous ne voulions pas commencer par la
censure contrairement aux insoumis c'est
parce que nous voulions que le débat ait
lieu
pourquoi parce que dans le débat on a
fait apparaître progressivement à la
fois les impensés les autres les
improvisations et surtout les injustices
que contenait ce projet et il fallait
que le débat ait lieu
nous aurions même souhaité qu'il aille
jusqu'à son terme et le 49-3 nous en a
empêché payante médiatiquement 7
cette stratégie des 20000 des vingt
mille amendements et c'est le jeu
parlementaire vous assumez parce que çà
et là bon dos les raisons baudot les
médias mais vous savez comment ça marche
le système
oui ça n'empêche pas de sur le système
médiatique comme sur le thème économie
comme sur le système politique de
parfois penser que parce que il ne
fonctionne pas comme il devrait
eh bien on n'est pas obligé de
fonctionner de dysfonctionner avec lui
et donc dans cet épisode sur les
retraites nous avons cherché à chaque
fois et vous venez de montrer à
l'instant les images de la caution des
as à tapha social d'hier ou cherchons à
voir une commission d' enquête sur
l'étude d'impact qui aurait dû informer
loyalement les parlementaires sur ce que
sont les conséquences de cette réforme
est recevable a dit la commission des
affaires en opportunité les
parlementaires de la république en
marche ont fait le choix de ne pas
laisser les parlementaires accéder à la
vérité c'est ça le sujet c'est que ils
ont peur que nous puissions à cette
occasion manquée de faire apparaître
cette étude pour ce qu'elle est mais tu
te faut c'est truqué qui était
totalement biaisé cherchait simplement à
faire a prétexté qu'on ne peut pas faire
une commission d enquête sur ma joue
l'étude d'impact parce qu'elle ne porte
pas sur des faits écoutez je donne leur
d'arguments oui c'est l'argument
maintenant le passé il ya eu là tous les
cas bien sûr c'est arrivé cette série v
sur les 35 heures la droite avait
demandé une étude doivent noël que son
enquête sur l'impact des 35 heures et
nous l'avons autorisé vous ne pouvez pas
faire de recours contre ce refus
vous êtes mes pieds et poings liés
malheureusement alors ça ne veut pas
dire que nous ne continuerons pas à
travailler et à faire apparaître au
grand public en auditionnant les experts
vous rendez compte quand même y compris
celui qui a été l'instigateur mais qui
était celui qui a pensé le système à
points antoine bozio a commis dans le
journal le monde une tribune où il
explique lui même que l'étude d'impact
une étude qui est complètement fausse a
c'est quand même incroyable et on
demande aux parlementaires de bien
vouloir voter le doigt sur la couture
une réforme dont ils ne connaissent ni
le financement ni les conséquences
inimaginables
c'est la honte du parlement en réalité
d'accepter en fait d'être traité de la
sorte et je serai à paris auprès de la
république en marche aujourd'hui je
partirai savait qu'il y en a qui partent
tous leurs tendez la main et c'est
heureux qu'il parte ils feront ce qu'ils
voudront ils iront ils voudront est-ce
que vous tendez la main rien à manger
de plus il ya 83 d'action se retrouvent
danseurs qui est sûr et revenir à la
maison
s'il se retrouve dans ce que nous disons
ils seront les bienvenus si c'est pour
dire qu'il continue à défendre la flat
tax la fin de l'es7 ils peuvent revenir
s'ils adhèrent à vos idées comme tous
les françaises et français si je moi je
je ne suis pas là pour juger
les gens sur leur passé mais sur ce
qu'ils veulent faire et tout ce qui
m'intéresse c'est ce que les gens sont
prêts à dire c'est des gens qui sont qui
sont des repentis m'a écouté ton mieux
il faut citer on va on va revenir un peu
sur sur la politique sur le ps notamment
où on en est sûr les retraites on croit
que c'est fini a toujours une petite
bagarre eh bien écoutez ça y est on a
les députés ont fini ils ont adopté le
second volet 1 c'était le volet
organique sur le système universel de
retraite c'est allé très très vite je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi mais
regardez en images le 10 41 et les seize
identiques ne sont pas défendus 826 et
17 aides en tic ne sont pas défendus
donc les sous-amendement tombe
voilà on a accéléré un petit peu après
effectivement bien pourquoi ils sont pas
défendus casque à gauche de l'hémicycle
il n'y avait plus personne pour les
défendre pourquoi et bien parce que
depuis le matin il y avait de la tension
dans l'hémicycle le ministre laurent
pietra chez ce qui est la rapporteure
sans drame autant eh bien il avait
refusé d'argumenter certains de leur
refus d'amendements il disait seulement
défavorable ça ça a profondément agacé
la gauche les insoumis notamment pour
eux c'était une façon et bien
d'accélérer et de finir vite les débats
ça ne leur a pas plu du tout écouter
clémentine autant députés en sont mises
de seine-saint-denis là nous sommes dans
une vraie comédie une triste comédie qui
s'appelle tout simplement un simulacre
un simulacre de démocratie
c'est une mascarade mes chers collègues
c'est une mascarade et maintenant je
crois que pour les oppositions à la
gauche de cet hémicycle
il est temps de tirer le rideau ça
suffit et pour reprendre les termes de
l'écrivaine virginie despentes
nous aussi on se lève et on se barre
alors il a fallu attendre un petit peu
un tout ce ne soit pas parti avec pertes
et fracas
parce qu'il ya eu une série de rappels
au règlement donc il a fallu attendre
que monsieur woerth prennent la parole
que la socialiste valérie rabault le
fasse également et puis les trois
groupes d'opposition finalement les
insoumis les communistes et les
socialistes et bien il on a décidé de
quitter cet hémicycle laissant donc la
république en marche
la droite et le modem seul dans
l'hémicycle alors évidemment cette
décision elle a été dénoncée tout de
suite par les marcheurs par le premier
d'entre eux le patron du groupe la
république en marche
gilles legendre il a continué a filé la
métaphore indus
spectacle pour eux ce sont de mauvais
acteurs qui ont quitté une mauvaise
pièce écouter avant que maintenant ces
groupes ont deux stratégies soit la
stratégie du débat obstrué soit la
stratégie du débat avorté
personne ne sera dupe dans les deux cas
ce qu'il n'aime pas c'est le débat le
débat il a repris à 15 heures ça c'est
bouclé très vite en deux heures la
majorité elle était bien seul au moment
du vote puisque la droite elle aussi a
décidé de quitter l'hémicycle
elle demandait un vote solennel sur le
texte qu'elle n'a pas obtenu les
marcheurs la majorité était donc bien
seul
merci beaucoup à travailler la scène
phare est sur un coup d'éclat cette fois
ci tous ensemble toute la gauche
vous quittez vous quitter l'hémicycle
vous garderez quoi finalement c'est le
débat s'est pas seulement un coup
d'éclat c'est une protestation profonde
sur ce qui s'est passé dans ce débat
vous rendez compte que on parle d'un
sujet qui représente un quart de la
dépense publique que c'est un sujet qui
va toucher tous les françaises et
français pas un seul n'échappera à la
décision qui est prise aujourd'hui par
président de la république et par la
république en marche
pas un seul et c'est le vrai théâtre
c'est d'avoir eu un gouvernement qui a
d'abord présenté un texte quatre jours
plus tard a demandé aux parlementaires
d'être en commission six jours plus tard
être amené à déposer tous leurs
amendements
avoir entre temps digérer l'étude
d'impact que je les dis que j'ai décrite
comme fausse et c'est nos 1000 pages
et puis après treize jours 12 petits
jours pour bien vouloir examiner cette
réforme
c'était déjà trop pour eux mais c'est
insupportable
cette façon de traiter le parlant cette
façon de considérer les oppositions
cette façon de ne pas êtres y compris en
réponse parce que ce qui s'est passé
depuis ce matin c'est que le
gouvernement ne répondait plus hors la
loi organique ça paraît un peu chaque
prêt un peu touffu de quoi on parlait on
parlait d'une règle d'or d'une règle
d'or qui va faire que désormais en fait
selon la génération à laquelle vous
appartenez en fonction la situation
économique
vous ne toucherez pas la même pension on
vous dit que j aime et universel mais il
recèle de quoi en fait c est né à telle
date ou à telle autre
si vous avez un frère ou une soeur qui a
un an de plus ou deux ans de plus que
vous
et qui a une carrière identique à la
vôtre selon le moment où vous partir à
la retraite vous ne toucherez pas la
même chose
est ce que c'est normal et ce sera
décidé par sarah décider comment ce sera
aujourd'hui c'est une décision qui est
prise souverainement par le parlement
demain ça se fera dans l'obscurité est
totale et donc vous aurez une variable
qui sera une variable permanente ce
seront tous les pensions ou l'âge de
départ à la retraite a laissé très clair
on pourrait comparer tout petit peu de
politiques et de l'avenir de votre parti
mais d'amour ça m'intéresse d'avoir
votre votre regard sur ce 49,3 ce
passage en force et au fond cette
atmosphère un peu délétère de faim de
fin de partie sur les retraites moi j'ai
toujours défendu le fait que la réforme
des retraites était inutile on a un des
systèmes des retraites les plus
performants au monde avec un taux de
pauvreté mais sur la méthode sur la
manière dont s'est passée à la faute et
alors bon après moi je recommande pas la
méthode politique ce que je dis ce que
je vois pour parler un petit peu de mes
bouquins c'est que il y avait un moment
une possibilité de débat aujourd'hui on
vous seront bien content depuis grand
débat que le débat est tronqué en
réalité ou fait semblant de débattre n'y
a pas de vrai débat
donc il faut utiliser d'autres moyens
pour bloquer en réalité cette réforme
est là le 49-3 montré qu'il y avait une
espèce d'impasse pour le gouvernement
d'aller sur la discussion des
amendements ou autre ce qui passe en
force
maintenant on parle d'un instant quand
même de votre parti et des élections qui
sont presque vitale pour pour le parti
socialiste
bon il ya des règles de csa qu'on va pas
trop en parler parce que ça ouvrirait un
compte c'est compliqué sur lcp
mais quand même c'était pas c'était pas
terrible à stratégie aux européennes on
imagine que vous voulez faire faire un
peu mieux
le ps a perdu 60% de ses cadres 30% de
ses militants presque plus de candidats
mais son mais son logo
voir avec la maire de paris notamment
comment vous allez faire d'abord oeuvré
si ce parti là un avenir les bulletins
de vote anne hidalgo il y aura le poing
et la rose
donc ce n'est pas aujourd'hui sur des
affiches elles sont vertes 1 je vous
sais pas vous permettre de faire un
scoop je vous le donne devra le logo du
parti socialiste les dernières affiches
de l'affection foire voix hier pour la
sur lci auquel je n'ai pas pu voir
puisque j'étais à besançon en meeting
avec lui un bayou notamment yell harper
l'a rappelé qu'elle était candidate du
parti socialiste notamment
donc il n'est pas temps dépassé ce parti
socialiste peut-être pour 2022
même le bar en noir c'est du prix de
voir sur canal+
non mais c'est vrai est ce que est ce
qu'on peut encore gagner cette élection
présidentielle avec cette étiquette mais
qu'est ce que j'ai cherché dans les
élections municipales d'ailleurs comme
dans les élections européennes j'ai je
dis des choses de manière assez
cohérente à ses constantes jeudi je
pense que les partis dans leur forme
actuelle qui date du 19e siècle sont
dépassées que les formes non seulement
organisationnel même y compris nous
devons chercher aujourd'hui à construire
une force qui soit une force pour le 21e
siècle et elle doit évidemment alliés
l'alliance sociale qui n'a pas disparu
on le voit avec les retraites avec
l'assurance chômage etc
avec le taux de pauvreté est bien sûr ça
doit aussi prendre en compte le fait que
aujourd'hui la planète elle même menacée
et donc il faut marcher sur deux jambes
une jambe sociale une jambe écologique
est évidemment dans tout ça il faut
aussi mettre de la démocratie ce
parti-là 7 ce bloc là je sais pas si
c'est un parti je sais plusieurs parties
mais peu importe les seizièmes à partie
peut-être par a des idées mais pas
freiné par la taille s j'étais hier soir
à besançon
je soutenais une candidate qui n'est pas
socialiste qui est écologiste
mais qu'a fait une liste de
rassemblement la scala il y avait 600
personnes qui étaient là des gens qu'il
est de tous les horizons des
syndicalistes des associatifs des gens
qui n'avaient jamais fait de politique
et des gens qui étaient tous heureux
d'être ensemble heureux parce qu'ils
avaient enfin le sentiment qu'il y avait
une espérance qui pouvait soulever une
espérance qui tenait à quoi qu'on avait
des gens qui ont enfin avait compris une
chose c'est qu'on n'ait pas simplement
là pour se regarder chacun
concurrencé à cons qui ont considéré que
le principal adversaire est celui qui
ressemble le plus facile
celui là mais avec la native à maquereau
et l'om prend le visage du parti
socialiste en tout cas c'est un enjeu
majeur vous êtes plutôt ségolène royal
ou bernard cazeneuve
mais je suis pour que nous commencions
par le fond nous commencions c'est
l'avenir du parti non mais attendez
j'essaye de dire des choses simples pour
autant je pose des questions oui mais la
question simple c'est que vous voulez
toujours ramener les questions alexandre
d'incarnation je veux d'abord à des
questions doit être ça compte et ça
comptera le moment venu parce que
l'incarnation à chaque fois on sait
comment ça se passe thoune joue la cause
des petits chevaux et à la fin ils sont
tous envoyé à l'écurie moi ce que je
veux c'est qu'au contraire on puisse
accorder sur le fond avoir un candidat
qui soit le plus unique possible à
gauche et que nous puissions demain
porter une alternative claire à la fois
à marine le pen
emmanuel macron si on commence par
l'incarnation on finira dans les uns
contre les autres c'est pas du tout ça
qui me fait sourire c'est qu'en fait on
a parlé du corps aux navires juste avant
et qu'elle a tous et c'est tout avant de
parler de votre de votre livre thomas
porcher j'avais envie de vous faire
réagir tous les deux à cette image
ces images d'ailleurs qui ont choqué
toute l'europe
regardez ça s'est passé lundi dernier
des migrants attaqué en mer par des tirs
à balles réelles de garde côtes grecs ce
sont des tirs de sommation qui ont été
observés la situation sécuritaire est
évidemment extrêmement tendue à la
frontière entre la turquie et la grèce
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui se
passe comment on peut laisser faire ça
c'est la bonne question comment peut-on
laisser faire ça
comment l'europe peut-elle être à ce
point dans la trahison de ce qu'est sa
propre histoire ce qui sont ses propres
fondements
nous sommes nés tous ensemble au
lendemain d'une guerre qui a été une
guerre mondiale et donc voir aujourd'hui
ces images c'est intolérable
c'est insupportable mais ça n'est pas
seulement l'action des grecs enfin
attention aussi à ne pas c'est
évidemment le probable dans aer dogan
qui en fait la question c'est la
question aussi la solidarité européenne
de ce mécanisme
absurde qui fait qu'on a renvoyé sur les
pays qui sont les pays d'entrer dans
l'union européenne
l'essentiel de la charge tout en
acceptant pas de la mutualiser sur
l'ensemble du continent et macro avant à
la veille de ces images-là sa solidarité
avec la grèce est prêté à l'assistance
de la france à la grèce pour protéger
des frontières ajoutant qu'il fallait
évidemment éviter une catastrophe
humanitaire migratoires elle est à la
hauteur
la france dans cette crise mais écoutez
brion la république c'est toujours enfin
peut-être parce qu'il énarque mais à
l'oral le grand oral c'est toujours très
réussi il ya toujours les bons principes
les bonnes valeurs et c'est quand on
passe d'un seul coup à l'application
lanrelas ya plus personne nous avait
déjà tiré des larmes de crocodile au
moment où on a découvert que les
passeurs libyen pouvait être de mèche
avec les garde-côtes libyens que tous
ces gens là à alimenter un réseau de l
esclavage et donc à ce moment là on
avait dit c'est intolérable
et figurez vous que c'est la france qui
a fourni ensuite le matériel ou
garde-côtes libyens pour qu'ils assurent
eux-mêmes
ce que nous ne voulons pas faire moi je
il ya un moment où il faut quand même
arrêter l'hypocrisie
je n'ai pas grand chose à ajouter c'est
effectivement c'est une honte c'est une
honte
il ya une vraie question là-dessus
européenne parce que les accus l'accord
de dublin est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement mal mal ficelé en réalité
donc sur les pays qui sont directement
en face de l'immigration qui doivent en
payer le coût mais c'est aussi des pays
qui ont vécu qui ont subi les plus
grosses réformes d'austérité ces
dernières années donc ils sont très
appauvrie donc il ya vraiment quelque
chose de l'économique de macro
économique global qui fonctionne plus il
ya quelque chose finalement une qui nous
renvoie à nous-mêmes là dessus dans le
cas de l'europe dans votre livre on est
via les délais c'est donc chez fayard
comment transformer un bloc divisé en
force majoritaire alors les délaissés
pour vous ce sont les perdants de la
mondialisation les victimes de la
mondialisation vous essayer au fond de
les fédérer de les unir dans une forme
de projet politique un on peut dire ça
comme ça mais qui sont qui sont-ils vous
avez quatre catégories d gilet jaune
les agriculteurs les banlieusards et les
cadres moyens pourquoi cela
et que représente-t-il alors en fait
j'ai fait quatre catégories qu'on oppose
volontiers j'ai dit dans l'introduction
qu'elle n'était pas parfaite mais c'est
des catégories qu'on oppose on oppose
souvent par exemple les gilets jaunes et
les cadres on va les opposer les
agriculteurs et les habitants des
quartiers populaires
mais en réalité tous ces gens à
différents niveaux et malgré des
différences géographiques sociales et
culturelles sont victimes d'un même
modèle économique qui est le modèle basé
sur le triptyque mondialisation
financière et la scion de l'économie et
austérité budgétaire
c'est ça que je dis c'est une réalité
ils représentent l'écrasante majorité
4 prenez les cadres moyens et cadres
moyens quand tu commences à travailler
ils sont dans le top 30 % des revenus
répartir des revenus les plus riches
mais en réalité quand il travaille 80 %
une grosse majorité travaille sur paris
ils vivent dans un studio ou un deux
pièces vous regardez les derniers
chiffres sur les salariés et les 15
dernières années leur pouvoir d'achat
ont diminué et moi j'ai un ami qui était
cadre pour pour citer un exemple concret
qui était sur sa trottinette à paris les
il est tombé il a été aux urgences et 12
heures d'attentes pour se faire recoudre
donc l'austérité ils la vivent dans deux
catégories celles et subjectif c'est
vous qui la construisent et y'a pas les
ouvriers vous citez pourtant karl marx
en ouverture tout à fait de votre
ouvrage vous parlez au fond d'une
conscience de classe vous voulez
conscientiser ces gens là pour au fond
les faire se réveiller s'unir n'existe
plus ici et ici parce que les habitants
des quartiers populaires par exemple
donne l'exemple de la courneuve 70% de
la population la courneuve c'est des
ouvriers des employés les gilet jaune
paraît une grosse majorité qu'il a bâti
une grande une grande majorité des
habitants des territoires les gilet
jaune c'est les catégories b et
fonctionnaires des 4 go des catégories c
les employés des ouvriers
donc ils sont inclus dans les catégories
que des exemples concrets au fond de ce
triptyque dont vous parlez
mondialisation en ancien risation non
mais sur qui sont les gilles et jo les
agriculteurs choisissez un mail order
puisque vous en parlez en introduction
puisque vous convenait de la
seine-saint-denis
qu'est-ce que vous avez avec eux compris
et ben vous regardez en fait il ya
beaucoup de dettes dash hélène quand
même là où mes grands mais mais ma mère
a grandi elle a grandi dans une tour au
tilleul qui logeait en fait la zone
industrielle de blanc mesnil et du
bourget à côté dans les années 90 il ya
une grosse partie des usines qui sont
qui ont quitté qui ont délocalisé et
donc les gens ont été mis au chômage les
taux de pauvreté ont grimpé d'un seul
coup à 50% soit pauvre
et à 50 % de ces populations un effet de
la mondialisation
ceux qui sont restés la financiarisation
de l'économie qui donne de plus en plus
une part importante des profits aux
actionnaires à exercer une pression sur
ces gens là vous voyez sur les gens qui
sont restés salariés une collision ne
sont pas partis et sur l'austérité
budgétaire elle est très simple vous
allez aujourd'hui vous regardez mon
ancien lycée à la courneuve on a
supprimé les cours du soir on a passé
les classes de 28 à 35 parce qu'il ya
plus de moyens pour l'éducation
alors que la population de la courneuve
est majoritairement plus jeune qu'à
paris et qu'elle est en décrochage
scolaire plutôt donc là vous avez une
conséquence concrète à la vie
quotidienne des gens et c'est ça que je
veux dire en fait est que aujourd'hui
quant à politiques parlent ils parlent
toujours de grandes masses monétaires
oui on va réduire difficile d'un point
on va économiser 15 milliards sur la
qualité 11 milliards sur les
collectivités locales voilà on parle
mais il ya toujours une conséquence au
bout sur des individus il n'y a pas
besoin de rentrer des données sur excel
et de faire une régression sur un siècle
pour se rendre compte qu'en fait il ya
des conséquences concrètes qu'on peut
voir autour de nous voilà alors ce qui
est intéressant quand vous dites oh on
les a opposés on oppose les gilets
jaunes aux agriculteurs aux banlieusards
ne s'est pas c'est pas on sait qu'ils
ont c'est le système je connais pas vous
avez bien vu que les régies des jaunes
et les habitants des banlieues ne
s'était pas mélanger et il ya eu des
enquêtes et des reportages pendant que
ça c'est faux de dire s'il n'y a pas eu
de jonction du mouvement l'hérault alors
attention attention attention
déjà la première chose quand je dis aux
gens parlent au début c'est les partis
politiques qui instrumentalisent la
division entre pauvres pour faire leur
fonds de commerce le front national il
oppose volontiers les les travailleurs
français des gens des banlieues
d'origine étrangère macron il oppose les
fonctionnaires les salariés du privé où
les chômeurs ceux qui n'ont pas de
travail et il avait dit des phrases et
moi si tu es chômeurs atteindrait pas
tous de l'autre et de ceux qui vont
travailler
donc il ya des oppositions comme ça
volontaires pour faire alors leur fonds
de commerce ça c'est la première des
choses
la deuxième des choses sur la jonction
en fait des défilés jouais bien je finis
la finition
extrême droite y en a qui sont définies
sur votre question oui mais laissez moi
finir sur votre question entre les gilet
jaune et les banlieusards il ya eu
beaucoup d'action commune et de tribune
signée d'appels à manifester par exemple
pour le climat signé par des
collectivités de banlieue dé gilet jaune
et même des activistes comme cyril dion
pour les marches pour le climat vous
avez la dernière fois une action qui a
été fait à place d'italie lyon qui a et
réalisateur il ya une action qui a été
fait de blocage d'un centre commercial
dans le 13ème place italie ça a été fait
par le comité adama traoré qui rendent
plutôt les banlieues extinction
rébellion et les gilet jaune donc là là
oui il ya eu quand même des convergences
des luttes il faut juste que quelqu'un
vous allez même des artistes je suis
natif des artistes contre la banlieue
par exemple comme cariste qui ont
soutenu les gilet jaune
officiellement donc on veut pas dire
qu'il ya une jonction et quand vous
interrogez parfois les mêmes une étude
qui est sorti qui montre très le pouvoir
ou les partis politiques qui au fond
attiserait les oppositions qu'est ce que
vous pensez de cette thèse déjà sur ces
catégories qu'il faut au fond réveiller
prendre conscience d'un commun pour
prendre le pouvoir parce que c'est ce
que vous expliquez d'une certaine
manière mais d'abord je voudrais dire
que effectivement moi je lis thomas
prochain depuis longtemps et que je lui
reconnais une première qualité c'est
d'avoir cherché à déconstruire tout ce
qui était les préjugés libéraux qui font
qu'aujourd'hui une espèce de culture une
culture dominante qui fait qu'on n'ose
même plus penser parce qu'on a
l'impression que quand on pense à côté
on pense faux et justement de remettre
jaillir pardon réfection de laïcs mais
l'église au milieu du village
parfois ça fait du bien et donc le
traiter c'était très économique
numériques critiques avaient permis au
moins ça c'est de dire à tout le monde
ne laissez pas non plus en fait des
thèses qui sont des thèses mais qui ne
sont pas en fait prouvé et bien prendre
le dessus sur vos vies parce que c'est
de cela qu'il ya des pressions de tout
le pays d'aunis et vous voilà comment
comment faire émerger au fond cette
cette idée de
de les fédérer comment vous y arrivez
encore une fois techniquement je ne sais
pas moi ce que je propose c'est un
programme économique parce que je dis
quoi là il ya des différences
culturelles
il ya des différences géographiques et
des différences sociales parce qu'un
cadre ne peuvent pas n'a pas la même vie
que 1,15 ouvrit un peu pas dire mais
tous sont victimes à différents niveaux
de ce système là donc il faut poser les
bases communes d'un projet d'un projet
unique commun qui passerait au-dessus de
la répartition différente des récettes
mais la dépense publique 100 milliards
de dépenses publics injectés dans l'air
une interne commencerait par 40
milliards oui car nos milliardaires avec
ce programme là on sort de l'europe
clairement non enfin on va devoir
établir effectivement rapport de force
avec l'europe parce que je crois que
l'europe ne fonctionne pas très bien je
suis pas le seul à le dire aujourd'hui
un homme accro au début ils abaissent
les déficits totalement ne peut pas pas
forcément déjà un pas forcément est la
première des choses
moi je moi je m'en fous des déficits et
je m'en fous du niveau de la dépense
publique en réalité moi ce que je veux
c'est ce qui a des besoins oui ou non
elle dans un hôpital aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qu'il a dit le chef de l'hôpital
quand il a il a parlé à emmanuel macron
ils le disent que tout va bien ce qu'on
veut de la de l'intelligence
artificielle pour soigner maintenant on
veut des moyens et on veut du personnel
vous allez avoir les allées voir des
pompiers qu'est-ce qui vous demande du
moyen des personnels c'est simple c'est
des choses utiles
on va mettre les moyens on en a retiré
40 milliards avec le pack de
responsabilité le cs 20 milliards avec
lisf la flat tax et la baisse et la
baisse sur lies faisait donc on n'a
jamais d'argent je sais pas ce que c'est
vous saviez force et c'est c'est
réaliste
ce programme là c'est parce qu'on ne
sait pas quand vient le temps de lire le
livre de thomas mais quand il dit on
s'en fout des déficits mais répond non
mais c'est une façon de parler
la réalité c'est que c'est une façon de
dire qu' on ne peut pas avoir une espèce
de religion absolue qui fait que
désormais il faudrait être un déficit
zéro
la réalité c'est que vous même quand
vous êtes vous achetez une maison vous
acceptez d'être en déficit pendant 25
ans parce que ça vous permet d'acquérir
un bien qui sera ensuite transmissibles
à vos enfants et donc attention à ne pas
toujours derrière des grands mots
peur empêcher sur ça que vous êtes là
justement développer si ces 100
milliards je ne sais pas on trouve les
100 milliards ce que je sais c'est que
je vais pas donner la solution ce soir
mais moi je le sais si si on commence
déjà par dire dsf la flat tax
s'effectueront 5 milliards par an si
vous prenez l'argent et c'est dans la
loi sur les retraites
une façon de financer les retraites
c'était de dire qu'on prend l'argent de
la kadey ce qui va en 2024 achever son
oeuvre puisque la dette sociale si on
parle de déficit la dette sociale fameux
trou de la sécu qui nous a fait
tellement parlé le trou de la sécu c'est
fini à 2024 donc il ya donc y'a moyen 4
milliards qu'on embauche chaque année à
bulles est à dire que vous avez 20
milliards qui vous tombent dans les bras
et vous pouvez l'utiliser pour l'hôpital
public pour la dépendance pour les
retraités
vous avez c'est un gars dont je vais
vous parler et on pourrait encore y
compris faire cotiser par exemple les
revenus du capital pour les retraites il
ya des gens qui en reviennent passerait
de monsieur blanchard qui était
économiste en chef du fmi après avoir
préconisé toutes les coupes d'austérité
qui ont saigné la grèce finalement deux
ans plus tard il arrive dans un article
en disant qu'en fait ils avaient mal
évalué les multiplicateurs aujourd'hui
la même personne vous dit que on peut un
peu creusé le déficit que finalement les
marchés financiers n'augmenterons pas
les taux d'intérêt qui sont négatifs sur
15 ans donc voyez il ya même des gens
qui en reviennent le problème c'est que
entre temps vous avez eu des vies qui
ont été sacrifiés une économique était
difficile des services publics côté
sacrifier et le vrai problème c'est
comment re donne finalement comores mais
l'économie
clarisse de l'humain d'un tout petit
bout parce qu'on parlait d'incarnation
ça compte vous avez toucher goûter à la
politique dans certains mouvements qui
pour incarner la voix des délaissés à la
fin j'ai rien dit mais peut-être l'objet
de mon prochain livre
allez merci beaucoup je vous invite à
poursuivre le dialogue et de lire les
délaissés de thomas porcher chez fayard
comment transformer un bloc divisé en
force majoritaire merci d'être tous les
deux sur le plateau de lcp très belle
soirée et à demain
[Musique]